como una pesadilla el miércoles un nuevo
Tornado atravesó una zona rural del
Condado de bollinger al sur de San Luis
en Missouri el fenómeno dejó a su paso
muerte y destrucción
realmente no sabía cómo sonaba pero lo
oí como un tren de carga y eso es
exactamente lo que parecía había cosas
golpeando la casa mi hijo salió volando
por el pasillo teníamos a todos en el
baño de abajo y yo no sabía si iba a
perder la casa fue una experiencia
horrible todos estábamos asustados
un estudio preliminar de daños realizado
por el servicio meteorológico nacional
concluyó que el Tornado tenía vientos
estimados en más de 200 kilómetros por
hora y dejó un rastro de destrucción de
más de 35 kilómetros en total 87
estructuras resultaron dañadas
lo iba a ir cerré la puerta trasera y
nos metimos en el baño y entonces
prácticamente se puede oír como golpea y
Cómo esta llan los árboles y sonó como
un tren cuando pasó por encima de
nosotros
El Tornado se produce tan solo días
después de que otros violentos fenómenos
arrasaran partes del sur y medio oeste
de Estados Unidos causando la muerte de
al menos 32 personas